all right here with reaction Hoover
institution senior fellow Victor Davis
Hansen former governor of Arkansas Mike
Huckabee Governor Huckabee start with
you uh when you look at the situation
what well first of all why didn't he
respond to the nearly 200 previous
attacks how could you not respond at all
and not have what happened over the
weekend become
inevitable utter weakness that's what
we've seen everything that Colonel North
just said I would just want to say Amen
to it what else can be said that was
exactly what we need to be doing I hear
some people saying we need to go bomb
Iran actually what we need to do is what
Donald Trump was doing and that's
bankrupting Iran that was effective it
was working and it was a far better
approach maybe we do need to bomb their
refineries but we don't need to just go
after and start another War we need to
do what Donald Trump was already doing
and it was effectively working I don't
know why we don't do it I'm so tired of
hearing Democrats say boy isn't it great
the Biden team is here we got the adults
back in the room no what we got was
senior adults in the room that don't
know what day it is for God's sake we've
got to have some people who are looking
at this situation with the danger it is
what Colonel North said is exactly the
prescription maybe Trump gets elected
and names him Secretary of Defense you
know what uh Donald Trump also took out
solomani Victor Davis Hansen um I don't
want America in a long protracted War
however we do have new military
sophisticated military technology where
we can push a button here in the United
States and with pinpoint accuracy hit
any any darn Target we want inside of
Iran can't
we yeah we can and that's why Iran Iran
knows that generally in history if you
are perceived that you'll do anything
for peace you're going to guarantee a
war and it's predictable that our
response is scripted we we say three
things first we say we're going to uh
respond to the time and place of our
choosing they that's they're tired of
that second we say while Iran has
supplied these surgat we don't have any
direct evidence that it's Iran and third
we want to avoid a wider War that's all
nice things but the message that they
take from that is that there's a magic
number that we haven't reached yet they
think is it 50 is it 100 we'll try 150
let's try 200 attacks is it six dead
Americans eight dead 50 wounded and they
keep upping it to find out where they
have to pull back for a while but the
problem is that deterrence is Sean it's
really hard to achieve and it's very
easy to throw away and when they came in
Donald Trump killed Soloman he took the
terrorist the houthis he put the
sanctions on them he cut off Hamas he
didn't want to get into the Iran deal he
rejected it he put in the sanctions on
the oil he had the Abrams Accord he had
no daylight between us and Israel and
when then when he got rid of soain he
didn't have to bomb around because they
understood that they were very in very
deep Peril but when you lose deterrence
then finally you're going to get to the
point where your only option is a war
and we don't want that and yet
ironically and paradoxically that's
exactly where Biden is leading us to a
theaterwide war the more that he says he
wants to prevent it and the more he
appeases these people that think they're
going to have a magic number until
they're going to keep going and until we
they're forced to stop and we don't want
a war but I don't know if he doesn't
reenter the Trump Pro protocols and the
sanctions and all of the terrorist
listing we're going to have a war and
that's unfortunate but that's what what
we get down to Biden keeps it up there's
got to be I I think you'd agree and both
of you would agree and I'll ask you an
exit question there's got to be a
proportional response here and to me I
think we're all kind of on the same page
I don't know the maybe the right way to
go about it but we've got to cut off
their financing here because the money
is financing the proxy wars and the
terror attacks all over the globe uh to
do that to me the shest way to do it
would be to take out their refineries I
also think that would be proportional
Mike Huckabee what do you
say I agree that you can take specific
targets you don't have civilian uh
casualties you also go after these
proxies and hit them hard hit them real
hard but ultimately it's bankrupting uh
but let them know that if that doesn't
work the bombing will start but let's
pray to God that Victor Davis Hansen is
right the last thing we need or want is
an allout War I think we can avoid it
Trump proved that I hope we continue
that strategy would it be wise to take
out their refineries Victor Davis
Hansen if we get to that we're going to
have to but I think it's much better to
be quiet and carry a club than loud with
a twig and the louder we are and the
more predictable we are the closer we're
going to get to war should just keep
quiet and I think he should be
disproportionate disproportionate and
then that will stop it but uh he's too
loud and he's too weak and he's too
predictable and that's dangerous that's
the problem deterr and nobody respects
him and China's going to keep buying
Iranian oil anyway but I appreciate you
both thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else